[Music]
on Monday the City of Buffalo New York
will hold a moment of silence to Mark
six months since a mass shooting an
event many now refer to is 5 14.
recently we returned to see how life has
changed and what many believe still
needs to be done
in the city of good neighbors
how did you first find out
Zaire called me my sister-in-law Carlson
said something had happened to Tops I
just dropped my son off at a track meet
I was at a t-ball game in a park a
mother son civil servant and mayor
four of the many lives changed on 5 14.
all now trying to create new change what
have the last six months been like for
you
cheerfully how
it's been hell on Earth zanetta
everhart's son Zaire started his first
job at the top Supermarket on Jefferson
Avenue less than a year earlier
authorities say on May 14th an 18 year
old who called himself an ethno
Nationalist and supporter of white
supremacy drove more than three hours
from his home and began shooting this
much
up down left or right
he wouldn't be here
how do you explain that
divine intervention Zaire shot through
the neck survived
ten others did not including garnell
whitfield's 86 year old mother Ruth did
it surprise you that this kid would come
here specifically to Target black people
no
we know for a fact that racism and
bigotry and white supremacy and all of
those things that they've always been
here I think that the only difference
today they've taken the hoods off they
used to wear hoods they used to hide
themselves now they're doing it out in
the open how much has the neighborhood
changed it's still the same right it's
going to take time Tim hoags is
president of New York State's Civil
Service Commission he was driving by
that day and arrived at the scene before
police and I saw
three bodies lying in in the parking lot
I'll be honest and and tops didn't do
anything to me but I haven't been able
to go into into the store since it's
open right why I don't know the Outreach
began immediately the area just a few
blocks away that used to feature the
Buffalo Bills stadium in the 1950s and
60s was used to provide counseling and
hand out food with the neighborhood's
only grocery store closed this whole
strip it was just the community coming
together and it reminded me of when I
was a kid as far as the activity the old
rock pile the old rock file right that's
significant I'm glad you know that right
and so this was a bustling area the the
bills used to have some great games here
the four people we spoke with are
convinced 5 14 should be used as a lens
to examine broader issues
Byron Brown is Buffalo's longest serving
and first black mayor we want to make
sure that Buffalo is remembered so that
we can prevent this from happening in
other places in the country zenetta
Everhart has launched zenetta and
zaire's book club that so far has
received more than 15 thousand donations
what difference do you hope this the
book project makes
very simple education education is key
to solving the problem of racism
because kids were not born hating other
cultures and other people it's it's
taught to us
and so if children are taught that black
people are just like them and they have
lives just like them and we start at a
very young age you will eradicate racism
I believe that 100
Whitfield is the city's former fire
commissioner who says he's newly
committed to a different kind of service
before May 14th
I'm part of the problem
I'm not advocating
I'm not speaking out publicly or
otherwise you know I I see this going on
in my community and in my country every
day
I'm empathetic
but I'm not doing anything
so I'm part of the problem too because
it happened to me now I'm involved
I can't imagine what it's like going
back into that store as an employee tops
was good to completely remodel the store
so it looks different it does not look
like the same place the totally
redesigned Supermarket was able to
reopen just a little over two months
following 5 14. and today nearly six and
a half million dollars from a survivor's
fund has been distributed
the question for these four is
what's next we want to build a stronger
Community there's an unprecedented
opportunity to do something about
these injustices it's going to take a
lot of money and it has to go into the
right places too I think the the thing
that was brought out is that the east
side of Buffalo or east Buffalo really
needs attention for an individual
outside of this community to be able to
Target
a store
and say hey I know that this is heavily
populated by people of color and only
people of color
that's a problem
plans for a permanent Memorial are in
the works right now in Buffalo and that
survivor's fund has sent out money to
more than 160 people so far incredible
piece powerful good timing